foreign
split when I was two and then got
divorced by some S3 and as long as they
can remember it's always been tumultuous
you know if one person uh wasn't gonna
is gonna show up to one of my events
growing up the other person wouldn't
show up there okay
so your parents are children
[Music]
and the world is going on this is John
with the Dr John deloney show show where
we talk about your mental health your
emotional health your marriage your
parenting who you're dating whatever's
going on with your in-laws we talk about
all of it on this show
whoo
so grateful that you're with us I know
you got a lot going on I know you got a
thousand you got a million voices
clamoring for your attention I'm so
grateful that you put your headphones in
or you got in the car and you turned uh
this show on and you're gonna sit with
it big news this is big time we talked
about this last uh on the last show but
I'm gonna keep beating this drum for a
while
available to pre-order right now I'm a
brand new book building a non-anxious
life when you pre-order this book it's
20 bucks that's it I'm gonna blow you up
with bonus items I'm super hyped as we
start rolling them out it's going to be
very very cool but um it also includes
instant access to one of um a keynote I
gave to a couple thousand people the
book provides six daily choices to
overcome an anxious life it is really
um my flag on the moon for those of you
who believe the moon landing actually
happened it's my flag on the moon it's
my stake in the ground to say the way we
are dealing with mental health in this
country is not working and we've got to
do something different so I know
um it's gonna be it's gonna be it's
gonna be exciting and um but it's a book
that will change your life change your
life wherever you happen to be this is
about real change for real people not a
bunch of theories not a bunch of
nonsense this is for you and your family
building a non-anxious life so go
pre-order it right now go to John
deloney.com and they'll have the link
there check it out all right let's run
out to Andrew in Spokane Washington
what's up Andrew
doing pretty good man how about yourself
how's life treating you I I would be uh
lying if I said it was anything other
than pretty awesome it's pretty good
right now
good that's great to hear what about you
man
uh you know everything's going pretty
good um you know outside of just some
issues going on with Stanley drama
surrounding uh you know getting married
next month yeah family drama that's
weird
I know I know it's not so what's up man
um so quick little back story uh you
know I come from a split home uh parents
split when I was two
um and then got divorced by the time I
was three and as long as I can remember
it's always been tumultuous you know if
one person uh wasn't gonna is gonna show
up to one of my events growing up
um the other person wouldn't show up
there oh God so your parents are
children
yeah but it's I I don't want to word it
that way but yeah I know they're not my
mom and dad okay so they're elementary
school kids fine I'm taking my ball and
going home good job parents way to go
essentially yeah essentially and you
know it's gone through um like probably
only a handful of moments my life that I
can actually think of that they've been
in person you know like my high school
graduation basic training graduation
those type of things
um well leading to my uh marriage next
month
um you know my dad found out that my mom
was going to be at the rehearsal dinner
and pretty much said outright that he
doesn't want to show up to it
and uh bye Felicia
I mean seriously seriously he is opting
out gosh that's so heartbreaking man
like I'm making a joke but I'm
heartbroken for you I'm sorry
it is difficult you know because me and
him do have a good relationship overall
and uh but my fiance and I were
discussing like what's gonna happen in
the future when we start having kids and
trying to plan birthdays around them and
those type of things
and um and so we try to discuss it with
them you know we've
um called them and immediately he got
defensive you know saying that we never
stand up for him
um and he has a lot of times in his life
were
doesn't have the best relationship with
friends or family you know and it's uh
it's been pretty difficult and we didn't
know if it was right for us to confront
him and talk to him about it
um but yeah we just don't really know
how to go forward with it you know it's
been pretty difficult yeah so here's the
language I would use
mm-hmm
I would say
um Dad this is my wedding
and
I'm inviting all of my parents
if you choose to not come it will break
my heart but you're a grown man and you
get to make that choice I hope to see
you there and that's the end of the
conversation
anytime he starts with you nobody ever
sticks up for me you guys have always
said
that Dad I'm not going to continue down
this road
what you're going to start doing is
practicing putting your own two feet
underneath you because you're now
building your own home
and you're building your own legacy in
your own trajectory ideally it would be
part he would be a part of that
and for whatever reason the whole
world's out to get him and he can't see
the forest from the trees and he can't
make hard choices through his own
discomfort for a in service of a larger
picture
and I hate that for you I hate that for
your kids when you have kids it will be
the birthday party will be here
everyone's invited
if you choose to not come because mom
came or if you choose to not come
because Dad came you're a grown-up and I
can't make you be here but it will break
my heart if you don't want to be around
my child
and that's it you you have no other role
to play your job isn't to make him feel
okay about himself
that he's a grown I mean he's your dad
that's his job
tell me why that sounds why that's hard
well you know I try to come from
understand because he did have a lot of
trauma growing up you know there's a lot
of things that he's gone through too but
hold on hold on that was then and this
is now
yeah and if he's going to continue to
let what happened when he was a child
drive the car through adulthood through
grandparenthood
then he is choosing to not be a part of
his son's life in his grandkids life
yeah it's a context not an excuse yes
his childhood was hell I'll give him
that
that doesn't give him license to kick
and scream like a child all through his
50s and 60s and 70s to the point that it
impacts his kids his son's new marriage
his grandkids and on and on into the
future that's how family dysfunction
continues
from generation to generation and you my
friend are being the strong one to say
this stops with me
yeah yeah your childhood was hard too
right
yeah you know I mean I I was blessed
with
um at least having two two parents that
loved me you know so I I try not to
dwell it on too much but you know it's
definitely difficult to try to balance
it and it was hard yeah I'll dwell on it
for you you don't have to and by the way
when you have a little one it will come
screaming back at you so just be just be
ready but I will uh just you'll remember
this moment you'll be like oh that's
what that idiot on the on the on the
podcast was talking about but I I'll
tell you it'll come for you
um and that's all good that's why you're
gonna have a great marriage you're gonna
work hard on having a strong marriage
you're gonna have some men in your life
that you hang out with and do life with
so when this stuff comes
um when those childhood memories come
running back especially when you're
holding your own kids
um you will you'll be absorbed you'll be
able to absorb it right it'll become
part of your life it won't be something
you have to run from and right now your
dad's still running and here's the scary
sucky crappy part you can't fight that
fight for him yeah what you can do is
set boundaries that will help you have a
whole marriage help you be the best dad
you can be to help your kids be whole
um and a lot of that's going to come
with some grief man because you're gonna
have to sit with a broken heart
wondering why your dad's dislike for
your his ex-wife is greater than
his love for his son
and that just hurts man
yeah yeah it's something that you know I
that's exactly how I've worded it you
know and it's something I felt really
long time
um and yeah you know like like you said
I just have to try to continue to do
better and make sure because it stops
here so there's I wouldn't say just just
try to do better I want you to hear me
say you're good enough as you are
you're a good man
I think it's a matter of continuing to
ask yourself what's the best way I can
love my wife what's the best way I can
honor her husband which is Andrew what's
the best way I can love and honor my
kids what's the best way I can serve and
honor love my community my workplace
um my God whatever whatever things you
know are are in the foundation of your
life
um but I think you're doing a pretty
good job the fact you're even asking
these questions and considering drawing
some of these boundaries tells me you're
way down the road man it's impressive
well awesome I I really appreciate that
thank you so much so here here again
just to reiterate my conversation would
be with my wife
and uh Mark your fiance you're about to
be married in a month and congratulate
congratulations congratulations by the
way I'm speaking super clearly today I
think I've had 700 milligrams of
caffeine so far today and my tongue is
moving faster than my brain you sounded
like Scooby-Doo
I think I usually do minus the Edibles
or whatever he was always on right I
don't know what Scooby was taking but
sorry Shaggy oh Shaggy his owner I think
they were both a little complicit but
back to Andrew back to Andrew I'm a
little bit distracted today
um
and I want you to sit down with your
wife and say hey who do we want to
become and what kind of home do we want
to have and that hopefully that home
includes warmth and that home includes
peace
because your home should be a safe place
where you and your spouse and your kids
and your friends and your loved ones
gather
as a shelter for the storm that is The
Madness of the outside world and if
family members bring chaos into that
piece and into that warmth then they are
opting out
and so sit down with your fiance with
your wife and say what do we want what
do we want this to look like what do we
want these boundaries to be and then
begin practicing saying Hey Dad this is
my wedding
and so I'm inviting everybody and if you
choose not to come it's gonna break my
heart
but I respect your right to make that
choice if you choose to not be around
our grandkids just because your ex-wife
is there you you choose your hatred or
your anger more than you choose your
grandkid I hate that but you get to do
that and I'll sit in that grief
but I'm not going to budge on my
boundaries
because I'm expanding love here I'm not
trying to constrict
Andrew hang on the line um I'm gonna
send you a copy of
both own your past change your future
and my brand new book building a
non-anxious life as wedding gifts
nothing says I love you like a couple of
books about emotional and mental health
right and I'm gonna send you both
couples decks
um so that you and your brand new wife
will have something to do for the first
month or two of your marriage or maybe
longer maybe more congratulations my
brother we'll be right back
foreign
here all right it's time to declutter
you got a treadmill covered in dust you
got magazines from five years ago piled
up in the corner a garage you can't even
Park in and all that clutter and mess
can lead to anxiety to just feeling
burned out and overwhelmed when you hang
on to the wrong things for too long it
can lead to something else bad sleep
that's right you might have the same
nasty lumpy mattress you've had for
decades just sitting up there gross your
sleep is way too important for that and
you're way too important one of the
easiest things you can do to improve
your physical and mental health is
invest in refreshing sleep and that
includes having a great new mattress
like a dream cloud and right now dream
cloud is making it a no-brainer to
upgrade your mattress with an offer just
for our listeners 40 off of all
mattresses plus an additional fifty
dollars in savings
it's time to start prioritizing your
sleep
clear out all the Clutter
get rid of that old mattress and go to
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
John deloney
that's dreamcloudsleep.com with code
all right let's go out to see
out to California and talk to Marjorie
what's up Marjorie
hey Dr John what's up
oh nothing much just putting my business
out there for millions of viewers to
here
hey man listen listen nobody listens to
this show Marjorie you know that it's
true nobody listens to the show hey I do
there's gonna be dozens of people dozens
dozens so what up how can I help
so um thank you
thank you
so uh my question is how do I
how do I emotionally be there for my
daughter while I'm going through grief
um and the backstory is my husband
passed away
um back in April
and so um what was his name
is Adam Adam
yeah he was all right
he feels all right we had a
Rocky marriage
um he was in
uh he was an addict and so
um
we were separated for the form gears
that we were married and so it was kind
of uh
I guess uh
while I was grieving you know through
the whole
ordeal and so
um how did he pass away
um that I'm not sure yet I'm still
waiting for the coroner
uh to release that information okay
um
I'm so sorry that's so recent
how's your baby girl
three
did she know Dad
or was there a lot of separation
um
both she knew him but you know there was
kind of a lot of Separation but she
knows you know she sees pictures and
stuff she knows that's her dad yeah
yeah so
what does grief look like for you these
days
um
I'm not wanting to do much yeah
and a lot of kind of circular thinking
and not being motivated to do things so
are you working right now
yeah
where do you work
um I am an Urban Farmer no way for real
you like you like sell like vegetables
and stuff
yeah
what else do you sell
unless they just produce produce awesome
yeah you do that year round
um no we don't do it year round just
mostly during the summer through the off
Seasons we kind of just are getting
ready for the
harvest season pretty much okay
so
here's the hard part
is
is a single mom you got to pay your
bills
great you gotta work
you got to make sure your insurance is
paid up you got to make sure those the
lights stay on
we got to make sure that baby girl's got
food
yeah and
you have to honor your body in this
season when it just wants to be quiet
for a while
and so it's a both and
what you're gonna have to do I would say
the most important thing and I'll give
you a list of a couple things that I
think would be really good just to have
check offs on on a note card every day
I'll give you those things but
you're gonna have to switch
your anger and frustration and disgust
that you have with Marjorie
and change that to curiosity
okay because you get really mad at
Marjorie when she don't want to get up
and go work out or she don't want to get
up and go do whatever Fair yeah yeah you
gotta let her off the hook for a minute
man the love of her life died
the love of her life died
and when you're in love with somebody
who really struggles with addiction
you know this day is coming
and you constantly ask yourself what you
should have done and what you could have
done and so the the shame cycle gets
worse and worse right
right you gotta let Marjorie off the
hook man Marjorie did everything she
could
Marjorie loved that man to the Moon and
back
even when she couldn't even be in the
same house with him because he wasn't
safe
and so when marjorie's body says hey
we're laying right here today
if you got to go to work you gotta go to
work
but I want you to honor yourself okay
okay now
here's a path out
not for suddenly feeling a million times
better anybody who's selling you that is
selling your snake oil okay don't do
that
um
but here's the path out
the path out is having a note card that
you fill out the night before
um the next day
and on that note card it's going to say
a couple of simple things one of them is
movement you gotta move
that can be taking your baby girl on a
walk
back in in a stroller that can be taken
her to a park
but you gotta move and the second one is
you got to get sunshine
you live in San Francisco that shouldn't
be too difficult and you're gonna but
it's gonna mean just for a few minutes
you got to get up and get outside
okay all right this is
this is those moments when I don't care
what you feel I want you to just
practice the discipline of I am going to
move today I am going to go outside and
get some sunlight and have a cup of
coffee outside
the third thing is you cannot do this
season by yourself
do you have some women in your life that
you can reach out to that you can talk
to
yeah I have a few
I would love it love it love it if you
had a once a week morning breakfast or a
morning coffee
one of your friends came over to your
house
are you into theirs and brought
knucklehead three-year-old with you
and what will slowly happen over days
and weeks and months is the light comes
back on a little bit
you're always gonna love that guy
and you're always going to be
heartbroken
how are you notified that he passed
um
someone that he was living with told me
okay
can I tell you one more thing
yeah
often when we lose somebody that we love
especially somebody who is hurting
or somebody who got in a car wreck or
somebody who was struggling with
addiction
our brain locks in on the hurt and pain
they were feeling
as though at the time of the wreck at
the time of the assault at the time of
addiction
using
and I wanted you to hear me say now
the atom's at peace
you're not hurting anymore
and for somebody who loved him for as
long as you did that was your that was
that was the dream right is that he
would stop hurting you let him stop
hurting and be with you yes
correct but it's easy to remember how
much he was hurting and to get locked in
there
bro's at peace now Adam's at peace
and hopefully over the next few weeks
next few months you can
have you written him a letter yet
um no all right that's your last
assignment we're gonna get a note card
it's gonna say move it's gonna say
outside it's going to say contact a
friend it's gonna say eat okay you got
to make sure you're eating are you
skipping meals
okay we're gonna be a good Steward of of
Marjorie okay
and by the way if you eat a few if you
gain a few pounds over the next few
months it's all good with me okay
um I want you to write three letters
okay here's letter number one letter
number one is
how much you miss Adam Dear Adam I miss
you
tell them what you miss
house and be specific I miss your life I
miss when you were sober and clear-eyed
how much you loved me I missed all the
how funny you were all that
letter number two is Dear Adam I'm so
angry I can't breathe
and let him have it
write down on paper how much you tried
how you went to the ends of the Earth
how he cheated on you how he did this
how he did this how he did this write
all that down
the third note the third letter is
Dear Adam
here's who I'm gonna become
I want you to tell them what kind of mom
you're going to be to his baby girl
I want you to tell him what kind of mom
and woman you're going to be what kind
of business owner you're going to be
start to write down the plans
okay don't do these all on the same day
maybe take a break between them and if
it gets really tough get a counselor
okay
and I want to get some of this some of
these spinning thoughts like you
mentioned the loops I want to get them
out of my head and out of my body and
onto some paper so I can look at them
okay okay okay
if you're a real gangster
a real San Fran gangster
um
when one of your friends comes over for
coffee
I want you to say hey I wrote a letter
to Adam can I read it for you
and I want you to read it in front of
somebody else
if you're just a regular gangster then
you can read it in front of a counselor
but saying these things out loud is
really really important
getting them out of your body is super
important but also reading them so make
a note card every night there's a
practice to this there's like a there's
a commitment to this writing it down and
don't just put in your phone on your
notes app write it down on a note card
the night before wake up that day and
just commit to doing those four or five
things
and then give your body peace
give your body peace there will come a
time in the next few months when maybe
you don't want to be an Urban Farmer
anymore maybe you want to move maybe you
want to do some other things awesome
let those things come and that's why
you'll have a group of women that you
can bounce some of these ideas off of
you can dream with you can think big
with get some encouragement or some
insights or some wisdom from
man you're still flat in the thick of it
man I'm so sorry that you lost the love
of your life
[Music]
we'll be grieving with you Marjorie
thank you so much for the call thanks
for being brave
[Music]
that little baby's lucky to have you
we'll be right back
this show is sponsored by better help
hey folks all of us need a little
guidance sometimes in life we're faced
with tough situations and choices and
the way forward isn't always clear I've
been in that position in fact I'm in
that position right now and therapy is
helping me find a path through it
whether it's a career decision
relationship at a Crossroads or some
other struggle you're facing you need
someone to talk with to move ahead with
confidence so if you've ever considered
therapy I recommend better help better
help connect you with a licensed
therapist who can walk with you on that
journey to discover who you want to
become betterhelp is entirely online so
it's convenient flexible and it fits
your schedule whatever your schedule may
be just fill out a brief questionnaire
to get matched with a licensed therapist
and you can switch therapists at any
time for no additional charge so let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com deloney today to
get 10 off your first month that's a
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right let's go out to Denver
Colorado and talk to the great guy and
what's up Diane
hey John deloney how are you I'm so good
how about you
what's up
I have got
ten on in my personal life and I have a
son-in-law and daughter who listens
frequently and he said you know who you
need to ask is Dr John deloney so so
here we are gonna here we are and I've
got a very moral or ethical person so
just so you know well I
well that is not true so I'm gonna I'm
gonna so I'm gonna kind of kind of let
it all out there it's a kind of a long
story I'm going to make it as brief as I
can because
uh go for it it's uh it's been a it's
been a long few years
five years ago first of all I'm 49 years
old I'm married for 30 years to just the
most amazing man
we have eight
incredible kids
and
um five years ago we took the kids up to
the mountains about three hours away
from home went mountain biking and he
was in he crashed his bike very very
severely suffered
um a traumatic brain injury
that almost killed him
um we spent two months in local
hospitals five brain surgeries had half
of his skull removed coma you know all
the everything just horrible couple of
months he regained consciousness
enough that they accepted him to a rehab
hospital eight hours away they said for
two months we'll do rehab and do the
best that we can so I packed up left my
kids with family members and I went
um to this rehab hospital for two months
and that two-month stay due to a very
serious stroke and seizures turned into
a seventh month day
and we finally got to go home he came
home with a trach in
um a feeding tube in his stomach I had
to learn how to put a catheter in all
you know I learned how to take care of
them so we could bring him home
I had so much Faith John the whole time
he would be healed I just I knew it and
I'm a religious person and we had so
much faith and we worked
so hard I knew he would be he would get
better at least better enough that we
could carry on a conversation with him
he would be somewhat himself
and over the next two years of having it
him at home it was a lot of work
um and he just never really
got better he did learn to walk again we
taught him to walk
um but ultimately his injuries are
he lost hearing he's completely deaf
um and he has no short-term memory so we
can't even teach him sign language
because he can't learn new things he
knows my kids
um he knows anything that happened 10
years ago or more but anything that's
happened about two years before the
accident and anything current he has no
idea he doesn't remember he's had three
kids get married he has grandkids I have
an eight-year-old he was kind of our
surprise baby and he doesn't he knows
that he has an eight-year-old but
doesn't really know him he forgets their
name sometimes
he has no concept of space or time or
age or distance all of that part of his
brain was
damaged
um
and two years ago
I decided for the sake of my kids lives
moving on in mind that I needed to put
him into a facility so he's in an
assisted living facility just a few
miles from home we go see him all the
time
um a couple months after we put him in
that facility we made some medical
decisions decided it was time to let him
go
and we put him on hospice and thought
the time would come that he would pass
and it's been almost two years and
despite
all medical odds science everything he's
still with us
pretty much no quality of life we've
prepared ourselves to let them go so
many times when it looked like
everything was heading that direction
and he's still with us and it's just
been so hard
to know how to move on
um
through this process I got my master's
degree
I you know I went back to school I I was
recently I've become an lcpc so I'm able
to work now and provide for my family
awesome so my question is sorry that
took so long but here's my question
okay can I just sit with you in that for
a minute yeah
but so so much
my um oldest best friend on planet Earth
is a traumatic brain Survivor and
um
when I'm with him now we go out I
stopped to help him go to the bathroom
um stuff to stop to have people take
care of and help him
um
and I can't imagine going up a hundred X
that with building a life with somebody
because it changes everything right
oh man changes the way you breathe
yep
and my guess is as a Mom of eight
you've been solving and fixing for five
years
yeah I have been
and you went and got a freaking master's
degree
like at some point it's at some point I
know have you exhaled
you know after about year one I did and
I still had so much hope and so much
faith and we would work with him every
day work on walking work on brain stuff
like don't let them just sit in front of
the TV like we gotta work with them it's
gonna get better it's gonna get better
and then after about year three
I just really had to shift my thinking
that this isn't going to turn out
how I thought it would
um so we cut we've we've come to peace
with it in fact we've come we came to so
much peace with him passing
that is what we've been praying for for
the last two years that it would be
better for him I mean you know you talk
about your friend and and and how that
is with him my husband is the same way
he would be humiliated
to see what he has become this is not
what he would want it's not this is not
the kind of life I mean he if he had his
rights since he would say why didn't you
just let me go three years ago why did
you keep me alive
and I listened to your last caller and
it breaks my heart the loss that she
feels and do you know what I'm thinking
is
why can't I be one of the people whose
husbands get to pass I'm in the position
where I'm jealous
of women
whose husbands just get to go peacefully
and don't have to live through
this pain and Agony that my family lives
through every day
I'm so sorry
[Music]
yeah sorry
because you're right you're right
hold on you don't have to make me feel
better you've been you you do that too
much to everybody around you
you finally get a glimpse they finally
get a little peek behind the curtain and
they realize how much you're hurting you
have become so accustomed to making sure
everybody around you feels okay
and at least at least for these few
minutes that's not your job with me
I get to be sad
that in the in the effort to save
somebody's life yet again we got so
sophisticated with our medical care that
we have put families in these positions
and
I'm sorry
so what's your dilemma question
okay
so I recently one of my husband's old
friends that I didn't know before we
knew each other reached out I I had a
CaringBridge account you know Facebook I
kind of would keep friends and family up
to date and I haven't posted anything
for a really long time so he just
reached out said how's he doing how's
the family doing
So I responded and we kind of struck up
this friendship
that's my dilemma but it was just nice
it was it was nice to have somebody talk
to me
on that level it was nice to have
somebody check in at night saying how
are you doing he's divorced so he's
single but I'm married and I promise you
it has not gone anywhere
you know what I mean it's just I listen
to me listen to me you're not crazy
you're not a bad person
okay here's my question okay it's
it's kind of a doozy
there's no doozies on the show go for it
I am considering
getting a divorce okay so that I can
move on with my life
okay
nothing with my relationship with my
husband would change one thing I didn't
say about his um
you know kind of his personalities he
he's very apathetic he doesn't care
about anything
I walk in he smiles at me I could tell
him
his kids took his truck and wrecked it
or whatever he wouldn't he wouldn't care
he isn't capable
of caring about anything so we go see
him it's mostly for us he doesn't
remember he doesn't really care
and
um just this little encounter I've had
with this man it made you feel it made
you feel alive really made you feel
alive again yeah absolutely like would
it be so bad if I
divorced him just for the sake of
getting my feet out of the concrete I
feel like I'm stuck in and start to
imagine
a future because for so long we thought
he's going to pass any day any day any
day any day and we've lived thinking
he's gonna pass and now I'm thinking
he could live another 10 or 20 years
like his heart and lungs are pretty dang
good his brain's pretty shot but he
could live
a long time
like this
and what does that mean for me and my
kids
I
it sounds like in all of the
if I was to distill down
well let me say this I want to be
careful how I do this because I don't
want anyone listening to this to think
this is the right path for somebody
who's having this conversation okay so I
am I am collapsing what would be a long
time of you and I getting to know each
other and hanging out and me getting to
hear all the stories and developing a
relationship with you before I started
asking you these questions okay you know
more than anybody else listening
how awful and Thoughtless and dumb and
just stitched into pillows the sayings
you get lobbed at you all the time right
you've got that for five years okay
right so I don't want to I don't want to
contribute to that
but at the same time for the sake of
this I've got I've got to expedite a lot
of this okay so this is just you and me
same side of the same side of the booth
just figuring this out okay actually I'm
not really the same side of the booth
kind of guy so we're looking across from
the at each other
um
it sounds like
through all of your prayers
the chief prayer overall has been
I want this to be exactly as I want it
I want this to the outcome of this to be
exactly what I want it to be
and
wrestling with praying for and I've done
this
praying for someone that I love to go
ahead and pass and then they don't and
then I have the guilt that I prayed for
them to die
and I can't breathe
and then I go through these like well I
guess I'll I guess they're here to teach
me something as though that's their job
right it just it just it never stops it
never stops right right I'm supposed to
get out of this there's still something
I'm supposed to learn that's right
I guess you said it best earlier
it's there's a coming to terms with the
fact that all the things you've prayed
for the last five years many of them
have come true they just haven't come
true in the ways that you wanted them to
yeah and the great challenge of just
being alive
is dealing with that gap of what we
wanted versus what we get
what I thought this would look like
versus reality
and that's the worst that's grief right
that's the black hole
and so go about going back to what you
said
this is for you
I would suggest
you're not crazy
I can't imagine how alive you must feel
to have somebody checking on you
who also might be a little bit cute
I cannot imagine
how lonely it is
not being intimate with somebody when
they're right there all of it all of it
but just from the few minutes I've heard
you on the phone I'm trying to project
out a year from now
would you be able to breathe
this isn't a judgment question at all
it's a curious question this is me just
asking Diane
if I were to divorce him would I be able
to breathe is that what you're asking me
I think I would
I I don't foresee that me getting a
divorce would change anything with him I
would have nothing to do with him has
nothing to do with him
it has to do with you saying for
sickness and health
right
I know he he won't know up from down
day one from day seven he won't know
you will
and so as as terms of your Covenant like
this idea and again I use that word
intentionally and I'm not even using it
in a religious context I'm just saying
there's so few Forevers anymore
in our culture
if you say no no I'm in forever and
then I don't have to look Diane in the
mirror you do
so if it's like yeah no I've done I've
done my duty and if my husband was alive
today nobody knows him like me it's been
30 years together
um he would be saying what are you doing
go hook up with one of my greatest
friends yes at least you'd be taken care
of
um
or
if you say I'm gonna figure out how to
feel alive and be alive inside of the
parameters life inside of this deck of
card this hand of cards that life has to
help me
laughs
because I said forever
I guess at the end of the day I can't
let you off the hook either way
yeah I can tell you
what I would do but I don't think that's
helpful here and I can also tell you
telling you what I would do right now on
this side of this thing actually
happening probably isn't um even true
yeah this is not something I in fact
people started
asking me early on you know would you
have you know have you thought about
divorcing them what did you and I just
was like absolutely not like that is a
ridiculous
idea
and it's just been long enough
I know if it were if the roles were
reversed
knowing what I know now I would tell him
go find somebody
go find somebody to be with and
be happy with and one thing you know I
am a religious person I've talked a lot
about prayer and faith and my religion
my husband and I were married in our in
our Temple and we were married for
what we call time and all eternity and
so one thing I know is if I were
divorced from him it would separate us
for this life
but I know and fully intend on living
with him in the next life
forever and I know that that's something
in my religion that some man would be
very cautious to even date me knowing
that I have been sealed
to my husband because that would mean
that whatever marriage we have
ear would not extend beyond this life
if that makes sense just you know kind
of as a frame of reference for where I
am at sure I I mean I don't have any
reference point for your religious
background but I would say based on what
you just said
if there is a if this is a cosmic
linkage if this is a forever together
what's the rush
if you truly believe that
uh-huh
do
and I know everything is going to work
out I know God's got a plan and in the
end it's gonna be but you don't like his
plan
I don't like
what I don't like it help but think with
30 more years in me
in this life
would it
you know is this idea of finding
somebody to have some companionship with
for the next
20 30 years
I know where I I can tell what you're
thinking it can you tell that yeah you
don't know you don't know what I'm
thinking you know what I'm thinking I'm
thinking I'm thinking how hard this is
um
and ultimately my my biggest you know
I've got an eight-year-old like I said
my next oldest is 16 and my you know
I've got older kids out of the house and
he is my biggest
concern at this point is this
eight-year-old that I have still at home
and in no way would I ever
do anything that would
you know make life harder for him or
jeopardize my relationship with him
for sure
well again not a judgment question but
just a question question
curiosity question
would you be showing that eight-year-old
that there is a boundary
to Forever
there comes a day when Mom moves on
what do you think
um
I don't know that's a tough one
I guess I guess I'll
I I'm not gonna give you the
satisfaction of telling you what I
really think give me permission no
chance just tell me what I want to hear
nobody never does listen no I I
hear a woman who deeply loves her
husband
I hear a woman who
has not yet opened her hands up to the
fact that you can't control any of this
and every step of the way you're
continuing to control continue to try to
control and continue to try to control
even to the point that you got everybody
together to plan for
the end
that you don't get to decide
and so
there's no possible way
I'm gonna sit in Judgment of you on any
decision that you make
I do believe that you get to choose to
feel alive and to be alive in whatever
context you find
I also believe that
for sickness and in health and Covenant
I don't know still means something
uh-huh
and
I'm trying to think of what my life
would be like dating Diane
who's like no no I still love this guy
I'm linked cosmically forever to this
guy I'm still gonna go take care of him
every week I just needed some cover so
you and I could hook up
oh there are certainly men that will
take you up on that I just talked to a
couple friends and that's what I said
like say I go ahead and do this like
what guy in his right mind oh don't be a
line of him Diane there's a bunch of
them Shady people out there no they'll
be there they'll be there
um they'll be there no question
but it all comes back to you
it comes back to you
and just talking to you
I think you're exhausted
and every plan you've made along the way
for the last five years has not worked
out as you wanted it to
and so your next option to try to
control what happens next
is what it sounds like to me to violate
one of your core tenants one of your
core beliefs religiously one of your
core beliefs in love
because you're real lonely
and you're really exhausted
but again it looks like yet another
attempt to control what happens next
because you've been out of control for
five years and I would suggest before
you go file for divorce
you spend some time with open hands
and fully leaning into probably with
your kids too
I don't control any of the outcomes now
and I'm gonna stop racing and seeking to
try to find another outcome that I can
control
and God Almighty yes it feels good when
people reach out
that feels good when you've been married
and you're happily married it feels good
when somebody reaches out and tells you
they miss you or they like you or
checking in on you
I would tell you to take a break
take a break from visiting for a bit
take a break from the divorce
conversation for a bit take a break from
talking to this guy for a bit
and maybe your prayer switches from
okay what about this okay what about
this okay what about this
and instead your prayer switch is to
I've got no control
and I've got no power
please lead me into what comes next
and again I don't know your faith
tradition I don't know your religious
tradition I know
you've been trying to control stuff for
a long long time
so sorry I can't give you I can't give
you my truest deepest thoughts on this
one
um what I can tell you is
unhook all the brakes
and just sit for a minute
maybe talk to your kids
and we get some wisdom from your friends
but seek to be alive outside of some new
romantic relationship for just a minute
seek to be at peace seek to open your
hands and say okay I could draw nothing
get me through tomorrow
[Music]
and really dig in on the promises that
you made for forever
because you're the one that made them
and if you make this other choice you're
gonna be the one that breaks
and Diane's gonna have to live with
Diane
thank you so much I'm so grateful for
your bravery you're awesome call anytime
we'll be right back
hey what's up Dr John deloney here check
it out my new book building a
non-anxious life is now available for
pre-order here's the great news anxiety
is not the enemy we've been led to
believe I know this because I've walked
alongside countless folks over the last
two decades and I've struggled with this
too if you create a life of
intentionally living out the six daily
choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non just life today for just 20 bucks at
John deloney.com
all right we're back as we wrap up this
show
um man that this last call cost a lot of
back and forth with the studio back here
yeah um and Kelly you brought up some
great points about
um I was I was locked in here and let me
tell everybody listening I was locked
into this caller and I was running
through my head in real time some
conversations I've had over the last 20
years with folks in similar situations
and I just didn't feel it was
appropriate to bring them into this
um without asking their permission so I
didn't
um
just knowing I've sat with people and
given like I think you should do this
next
um I didn't feel that was right here
just because I didn't they were on the
phone but you brought up some important
things like
if you divorce somebody do you lose the
right to visitation how do you split up
assets is that even you know what are
the legal ramifications How does it go I
mean that it causes all kind of
other mess that I mean you have to sit
down with a lawyer obviously and figure
all that mess out yeah I mean we were
just wondering as we were talking here
because like I know there's certain
States you can't divorce a pregnant
woman so is there any reason you
couldn't divorce somebody that's
impaired maybe not I don't know or but
also then if you divorced as the care
then fall to his children does that put
that on them
um because I know that she's got adult
children as his heirs or does it roll up
to Medicaid yeah where does that does
that would she lose her rights to make
all those decisions for him because I'm
assuming now you know she's got that
right is his next of kin so there's in
addition to the gosh
the like
man I just want a life part of it but
there's also the like you said the
spiritual part and then the legality the
moral ethical part in the league I mean
there's so many I
and it's like I know she probably feels
like damned as she does and damned if
she doesn't
I think there's 100 yeah yeah and I I
just feel for her that's just a horrible
situation to be in in on so many fronts
yeah I I
go back to
um
I was talking with psychologist once and
was really pushing me as a famous
psychologist I won't give his name out
but
um it was a famous psychologist that we
were engaged in a pretty pretty heady
one-on-one and it got heavier and
heavier and he kept digging into my
marriage and digging in my marriage and
digging into my marriage and
um I was giving him all of my Surface
answers as to why my wife and I stayed
together over we'll celebrate 21 years
next next week and
um
especially when there was times when it
got real gnarly right like we had
grown-up conversations about are we
gonna keep doing this and it um he kept
pushing and pushing and finally it
popped out of my mouth it's I it he was
like but why but why but why and finally
I said because I because a cup because I
said I would
and I landed on this
I didn't say unless dot dot dot I didn't
say there's an end to this I said I
would no matter how stupid and how dumb
I said I would and that sentence that
Covenant that I promise you till the end
of time
was what kept bring me back to the table
as frustrated as I was as lonely as all
those things
said I would and
um
can't I cannot
stress how grateful I am
that I had that I was that I anchored
myself to that sentence because
um the easy thing would have been just
to be like hey what's the cool Hollywood
saying this relationship has run its
course which I think is the most
conscious uncoupling conscious well
conscious and coupling is just like if
we're gonna get divorced let's be
grown-ups about it but like the just
this relationship just ran its course no
that means one of y'all quit driving one
of y'all took your foot off the gas and
you can do that I just don't buy that
that happens inevitably that's when
somebody makes that choice and I'm just
so grateful that I anchored myself too
because I said I would and I just think
as a culture we just have stopped buying
into that so that's tough that's tough
that's tough that's tough that's tough
so I don't know I'm gonna end today show
with I don't know
and I'm sure the YouTube commenters will
have plenty to say I love you guys stay
in school don't do drugs see you later
bye
[Music]